es el segundo asalto en una semana
después de haberlo hecho el miércoles
los partidarios del clérigo iraquí
chiíta moqtada al-sadr volvieron a
irrumpir en el parlamento de bagdad la
capital de irak
previo al asalto multitudinarias
protestas convocadas por la cúpula de
clérigo dieron a conocer su descontento
por la influencia de irán en la política
por la corrupción y tal vez su principal
razón de enojo la candidatura del primer
ministro del pro iraní mohammed zia al
sudaní
hago un llamamiento al pueblo iraquí que
tiene una historia de protestas para que
salga si quieres ser similar a las otras
protestas árabes
salgan y vean si pactaba al sádr les
obliga a tener un primer ministro
entonces podrán decir que moqtada al
sádr quería esto quiere que toda la
gente salga para que pueda dirigirse a
sí mismo
según fuentes de seguridad que pidieron
no ser identificadas los simpatizantes
de alzar rodearon la fortificada zona
verde la sede de la mayoría de edificios
gubernamentales y embajadas extranjeras
y entraron tras derribar los bloques de
hormigón que la protegen sin éxito las
fuerzas de seguridad usaron cañones de
agua y gases lacrimógenos para dispersar
a la multitud la cifra de heridos sigue
en aumento y el primer ministro en
funciones de irak llamo calma a los
manifestantes el primer ministro pidió a
las fuerzas de seguridad proteger a los
manifestantes y llamó a los
manifestantes a permanecer pacíficos en
su movimiento a no escalar la situación
y acatar las directivas de las fuerzas
de seguridad
desde las elecciones de octubre de 2021
se mantiene la parálisis política en
irak pues los legisladores siguen sin
ponerse de acuerdo sobre la conformación
de un gobierno y aunque se esperaba que
el domingo el parlamento tuviera una
sesión de votación para elegir un nuevo
presidente simpatizantes de alzarla
anunciaron el inicio de una sentada
dentro del hemiciclo